Hey my name is Andrew couch I'm a
business analytics student at Universal
and today I'm gonna Stan I go over the
tidy Tuesday series or data set so
basically every week tidy Tuesday will
release a data set for you to analyze
and make charts on so I thought it'd be
interesting to just do a video of my
process when I'm looking at a data set
and how I do a basic exploratory data
analysis so we'll go to the most recent
data set which is foods carbon footprint
well look at that and then they give you
a way to load in the data which is this
one little liner over here and we'll
just exit out of there pull up our
studio all do this thing and all this
analysis and our markdown so I'll do
tidied Tuesday co2 emissions and I'll do
it from a template which is a github
template to choose two missions all
right sweet remove that junk will do the
on a new chunk so creating chunks is
controlled ctrl alt I and will first
load in that tidy verse okay sweet and
then we'll load in the data set ok so
what's kind of cool with it that tie a
Tuesday project is that they basically
just give you a wider range of data sets
so for this one we'll just kind of look
at it it appears that there's a country
a category for each country its
consumption and co2 emission
okay so let's look at just how many
countries there are so we'll do count
country okay so we have about 130 rows
of countries and for each country
there's 11 other things that are with it
so I'm gonna guess that it is food
category all right okay go through that
so each country has its relative food
category and then I guess its respective
co2 and goods consumption of that
product so it gives you the consumption
of pork with its relative co2 emission
all right cool okay one thing that you
should probably always do that it's a
little bit easier just do a summary
function right doesn't only tell us a
lot about that but it does give us some
summary statistics at consumption and
co2 emissions so I'm gonna comment just
viewing the basic summary of the data
set well is it 130 countries right many
countries and eleven food categories
alright so let's just do a visualization
of that done on this nude
gather which just will let us gather the
consumption co2 emission and I just want
like a holistic approach so we won't do
it by country so we'll say that the main
thing is the feature with its relative
value and will ignore country and
actually yeah well nor country and Mayas
food category
so when now we just have it in a more
tidy format and we'll plot this out
where and let's see here yeah we'll just
do a box plot of it so color equals
feature box plot and I'm gonna do a
facet wrap so we can see each box plot
individually just so nothing crazy
happens okay so right here it's kind of
all over the what it's pretty bad and
you can't really understand this data
set right now this chart that's pretty
normal when you're dealing with like
countries because all countries have
like different population sizes stuff
like that so normally you're gonna have
to do like a log ten transformation okay
so right there pretty pretty easy to
look at awesome one thing that's kind of
interesting is it kind of seems relative
where co2 emission is basically equal to
the amount of consumption which kind of
makes sense
additionally if you see how right here
it's one e+ over three that's in
scientific notations so we can remove
that by doing the sigh pen thing you
know put it back to so okay so there are
there are a little bit different scales
right so that makes it way easier and in
fact if we wanted to fix the skills we
can see how it's a little bit different
right the distributions are a little bit
different cool okay so distributions of
co2 and consumption are not as
proportional as I
imagine okay and what's cool like this
is walk she just kind of do a little bit
more detailed of a plot and one cool
thing that I like to add is a genome
jitter where the Alpha is point like
four let's go that adds okay so that way
we can kind of see the basic density
distribution of it right which shows the
same story of the box plot but it's a
little bit more interesting I think
because you can see how the outliers of
this one of these the first graph is you
kind of just think oh it's just a few of
them when in reality it's actually a
decent amount it's not just like a
single digit of the outliers okay that's
kind of cool so let's see actually I
have one question on it let's go back to
you tidy Tuesday and I actually should
probably look at the data dictionary
first so what is their actual
consumption and emission so consumption
is kilogram per person per year so how
much each person how many children is a
food a person eats every year or is how
many kilograms of co2 is produced per
year okay that's kind of cool so one
thing I see is similar scales right so
we can kind of say kilogram per person
and then kilograms of co2 co2 produced
okay so I'm gonna get all that right
down something so consumption equals
hope kilograms ate by each person every
year and then co2 emission goes
kilograms kg of co2 produced
per person by each I'll do by each
person every year solid so one thing I
think is okay if we can just kind of
reformat this this question to like
almost an efficiency question so we can
just do some basic algebra remove year
so we want to I want to see like which
countries actually have like an
efficient consumption process where for
every co2 for it for every kilogram kg
of co2 maded how many kilograms of food
do they eat and you can kind of frame it
in different like honestly it's bear was
kilograms of kill or kilograms of food a
tune din produces how many kilograms of
co2 that's probably or that's probably
better to understand
although these both these actually
questions kind of seemed like the same
question however they're actually a
little bit different right
so like kilograms of food in a food
eaten and previous how many kilograms of
co2 one thing that would be interesting
for this is I bet countries that are
richer welcome are gonna be eating more
food which will lead to more inefficient
production of co2 however this one for
how efficient each food is Ian it's
probably buy produced by more agrarian
people but there should be a little
pretty similar so let's do something
that's a little more understandable so
we'll do every kilograms of food eaten
produces how many co2 just just to keep
it normal
so we'll do that okay so what kind of
suck that bad boy
come make sure we'll get up and we'll do
new tape and we'll do like food co2 per
food right co2 per food which is just
couldn't see o 2e emission / consumption
what we're gonna see you at E - hums
okay
and one thing I was I would be
interested in is like I bet food
category category plays a huge role in
that right so we'll do a buy food
category and we'll just like summarize
it and say mean equals actually equals
mean co2 per I will do average co2 co2
per right okay na and o have to do a
drop na
I know yet what going on over there okay
so there's some anaise that's kind of
weird
oops
hey I know there's summat huh that's
weird
what's going on oh maybe let's here
filter we're consumption equals zero oh
okay there we go
that's what huh oh that makes sense
okay so obviously in India they're not
gonna eat pork
I guess because that's a that's a
religious affiliation
mm-hmm okay so what we're gonna have to
do actually is filter consumption does
not equal zero
okay how about that so that way we'll
just do category y equals average co2
per food I wants to add Jim
see what that looks like huh
it's kind of weird and I'll do a
rewarder by average okay
okay so just did some basic formatting
all do uh I'm a fan of flipping box
plots or bar charts and then since we
don't really need the legend we can see
that we can just remove that since it's
all boy we already have the labels sweet
okay so that this kind of makes sense
right but one thing that I think it's
kind of kind of weird right is that
usually when people will say about how
inefficient food is we always talk about
beef especially in America when in
reality I guess lamb and goat is a
pretty inefficient food group I think
obviously I guess the reason why we
don't really talk about lamb and goat is
known really easily mango in America
especially where I'm at in the Midwest
but it's not we pretty interesting how
there's a huge discrepancy between like
lamb goat and beef with the remainder
right like on a co2 basis is just like
tenfold it's insane
kind of makes you re-evaluate how you
should be eating and additionally you
can see how like rice is a little bit
less efficient than poultry and eggs so
that's that's kind of weird
like poultry rice is more inefficient
than wheat kind of cool okay so let's
just write down what we observed right
okay was he lamb and goat is in
efficient and she probably also and
should probably be should probably
should be avoid be avoided
same with beef but I'm gonna say most we
everyone knows this then we'll say also
huh rice is more inefficient fish and
wheat that's kind of weird okay cool
so given these categories let's kind of
look at these distributions of like
consumption and all so let's just do a
kind of a facet style of or I want to
see the distributions of consumption
with all these food categories and also
co2 emissions and maybe let's see if
there's like some kind of relationship
with that so let's do that just wants to
select everything besides country just
do a basic gather I think you mean
actually app it we do this other one
normally I usually gather that gather
and spread function let's do like a
pivot wider and then now I'm gonna try
it consumption and co2 emission and I'll
do like what values from and then kind
of some shin and co2 emission let's see
how that works
oh god I didn't oh my god they don't
work oh it's cuz I did pivot longer
why don't why am i knew this names -
okay I'm not doing this I don't really
know but yeah the pivot why don't people
longer definite pretty useful if you
actually know what you're doing but I do
not want to know I'm going it goes - oh
my god okay there we go Jesus all right
and what do you uh another category y
equals value and we'll do color equals
food category box let's do a facet wrap
and then we'll do we want to do by
feature you know we'll do a fixed scale
and I already know we don't want to see
up is a legend so let's say what your
position equals nine again we still have
to do the scale y log 10 okay so we see
some cool stuff
I'll do another cord flip too cuz why
not
okay cool hmm it does look pretty
similar let's look at each distribution
one by one and we have to note that our
axis or axes I guess are are fixed to
some point cool so let's look at let's
look at the ones that we were first
starting at so let's look at lambing go
Salim and go alright here we can see how
right the median value is between point
1 and 10 and analog where is next eight
so you know I don't know what that value
is yet but it's easy to compare how this
median is much higher than the other
median really shows how like even though
it's not being consumed as much it still
is emitting a lot of co2 emissions same
with beef right beef the median
consumption is about 10 kilograms per
person however its production is almost
reaching towards like 8 like 100
probably like 4 4 to 500 kilograms of
co2 emission per person hmm cool I think
one thing that we kind of Justin you
just kind of look at it I can efficiency
plot so let's do like where we do like
consumption and co2 emissions as like an
X and a y-axis where I would say co2 is
a result resulting variable so we'll put
co2 emission on the y-axis and the
consumption on the x-axis okay that
makes sense
okay and then maybe we could yeah I'm
gonna do that we'll do like a well like
the food categories still be the color
and maybe this will tell an even easier
story to understand or I was a better
story right Co - oh my god
that's why it's a mesh color equals food
category
what do i geom point might have to do a
an alpha but I'm not sure and we'll do a
Jim Jim AB line right and we'll say the
slope is 1 and that is like total
efficiency where it's it's completely
impractical because like you just on my
physical standpoint where if you consume
something there's gonna be a lot of
wasted energy - but this is assuming
that like whatever car cataloger is
going this exact he'll always come out
it's like a perfectly efficient thing Oh
oops
ok so we can see something kind of cool
right however again with using
real-world data you see most data is
real world on a large scale as I guess
normal but it's mostly log normal right
so you can see how that is pretty cool
that's pretty interesting
which makes sense because also we
probably wouldn't need define um every
country's food consumption but we can
see how it's pretty straight and this
data it kind of makes sense on on an
efficiency standpoint how each food
category no matter how much consumed and
stuff will emit based this same rate of
co2 emission which makes complete sense
and it'd be honestly weird if we didn't
see anything crazy but I think even then
it's pretty cool however I'm actually
gonna do a group by category food food
category because there's there is a lot
of uh a lot of like junk right you don't
we don't need this actually consumption
so we'll just do the the averages but
what consumption no that's going on here
object consumption Oh oops
see that's that's why okay and that this
tells a fantastic story right we can see
how they see these residuals completely
off right how we have beef right here
it's super high and we eggs right where
eggs are Connor right on the line
they're pretty efficient Joe it's kind
of that's kind of a cool thing
okay in fact I could I could even just
do like a basic residual thing too if I
really wanted to and I don't know we
could do it why not okay
we'll add some residuals and this is
okay and then in with residuals and that
residual is gonna be co2 it's gonna be
was it co2 emission minus consumption
right hopefully I don't get that
confused yeah there we go and then we'll
plot that bad boy into ggplot and with
ggplot why the points right there we'll
also do a gym segment xn equals was it
was our consumption y and equals
consumption oh I guess I didn't really
need it okay and actually goes
consumption and y equals co2 co2 that's
pretty interesting
all right there we go we didn't actually
need to do the residuals but you know if
we want to wanted to plot out the
residuals on like a like a normal kind
of like do a residual plot we could do
that too well you can see right here the
difference between it is staggering
especially when you have a look at you
have beef and you have a lamb right
there and they're just huge and I guess
you can have I guess co2 emission isn't
it perfect
you have a tradition see but it's it's
still something of like proportional
waste on its a kilogram level because
you can see how what soybeans and and we
are are below in the line right so
that's kind of cool okay now what else
do I want to ask about this question
let's find is the most if a let's find
the top consumers of each food category
it is something where you probably just
don't even you probably don't need to
find the you probably need to find the
create a plot or anything because this
thing where your affinity to the top and
in a bottom end it kind of serves better
as just like a table I would say so
let's just do that
we'll say country and we'll say
consumption right N equals five milk and
cheese and then washed actually we'll do
a group of pie and then food category
that's pretty funny how these countries
consume a ton of cheese I guess cool
range by will do consumption
oops cool so we can see how I just ah I
guess we should do a food category -
okay so beef Argentina and Brazil those
make sense right we can see I want to go
back to that she the milk and cheese
thing I'll get right there
Finland consumes a lot of cheese I guess
I guess that makes does that make sense
because I would think Switzerland like
France and stuff would consume law
cheese I guess includes milk so that's a
little bit different okay and then pork
Hong Kong China ok that kind of makes
sense Austria
poultry Israel okay so one thing that I
would be interesting is ok so we have
all that we have the top 5 so top 5
consumers of each food category well I
think I may be interested in is like ok
so given always like top 5 kind of
consumers or of these foods
let's find like how many countries
aren't it twice or multiple times right
how many countries are like the
consumers of multiple products you know
there on the top end of all these other
food categories so we'll just do we'll
just do a count country oops
oh yeah
count country and boom right oh and we
have to do he goes true okay so now we
have these guys and this is something
where I would honestly want to maybe
plan on a plot but we're not sure yet we
can say on most these countries our
consumption level most of them are like
once right in fact yeah most of them are
ones however there are some people who
are on it three times and then two times
there's only one that's on three times
and it's Hong Kong in China and honestly
it's kind of weird how I don't see
America or the United States in it right
maybe the United States doesn't consume
as much food or maybe they just consume
a lot of food but in different
categories where they're kind of like
being spread too thin on it but okay
we'll just right in countries that
appear more than once in the top five
consumers buy and buy a food category
okay
and we'll do it I'll see you a filter
and does not equal zero boom tonight
cool oops one cool okay so one thing
with the tidy tidy Tuesday thing is is
that they they have different you know
we have our foods we have our foods but
we don't actually have like cat kind of
like these categories of foods right so
we look at it like we have animal and
non animal products let's just let's
compare that right that's that's that's
kind of a cool idea and obviously I
think there is come in puts it like Oh
non animal products are definitely more
efficient or less harmful to the
environment in animal products but I'm
kind of curious on like how much are
they better for the environment
let's do that and um I'm pretty familiar
with foods I think it can just kind of
manually do it but let's see what we're
doing here and what's you select
category we'll do unique I guess okay
nuts okay
so we'll probably just create a one as
I'm trying to figure out the best way to
do it I think the smartest way is just
showing in an inclusion in an or
statement so let's just find the ones
with the minority class and I believe
that would be non animal products
so we'll do wheat and eat products rice
soy beans okay and then nuts Inc peanut
butter okay let's do mutate let's do
look toast a good thing for food
category I will say vegan vegan okay
equals if else okay food category is in
boom this then will say non animal
product else animal product
let's see you does that make sense okay
and then I think one way to just kind of
make sure nothing's too crazy is we'll
do like food category we'll just do a
count food category buy vegan just I
like do a make sure nothing crazy is
going on right so if we
you shouldn't have like animal product
or nah nah no product and we can kind of
sort through it where yeah rice soybeans
no it's okay I said that there we go so
we got it and then I'm just gonna select
since we we just need consumption co2
emissions vegan okay
solid and honestly one thing that I told
forgot was just do a correlation between
consumption and co2 emissions right oops
nope so we have a correlation okay so
it's actually not as oily as we would
think it is okay it's not really what we
wanted you care care about but okay
again there's something where maybe we
should do a let's do a t-test right so
what's let's do a group group actually
will do a gather first equals type
equals value minus vegan boom and then
we'll do group by type
and we'll do a pivot wider names from
type values from there we go okay and
then we'll do - yeah actually we don't
you need that since we're just doing a
t-test okay let's do a t-test between
the animal and not animal for
consumption and co2 emission I will put
in the broom package though dope okay I
will do do a t-test I'm gonna I want to
look at the thing so we'll do the do
function which cannot the mutate
function for broom
I'm gonna say value to be vegan data
equals dot must be too dangerous
with you test i test so we just ran two
t-test and wants to our nest test what's
that
what is going on here what's going on
here oh that's why they're not factored
okay
vegan equals as a factor vegan hopefully
this will work now grouped by type duty
to test equals your test vegan to value
oh god what that test Eagle t-test value
to vegan data equals dot tidy tidy test
there we go there we go
Jesus okay so now we have a tidied a
t-test I totally forgot the tidy part
that's that's ridiculous
so what are we looking at so co2
emission is statistically significant
right we got we got that
however our consumption is not so people
may be consuming relatively the same
amount of vegan and non vegan products
so that's pretty cool
and you know just to do a basic test for
that just do a basic plot for it I guess
is a gym column let's giome H line y
intercept equals 0.05 right crazy yeah
yeah
so you see how co2 emissions is very
statistically significant I don't even
think I'll like me when I do is scale
log 10 yeah so it's very very
significant that's not good that's not
good why it's either just do that okay
so let's hear what else what else should
we ask for this mm-hmm
let's look at that country's actually
let's look at that again so select
country unique and so we got a decent
amount of countries geez 130 I'm curious
on what I would want to do with this
though
let's see yeah let's do most popular
consumption right so what do top and
actually we'll do it groups group by
country top and kind sumption any equals
one okay Wow
anyway what's to uh let's do a mutate
from our previous thing let's see if
most these people are eating a lot of
vegan foods or non animal foods okay now
they're all in on products and then
we'll do a count vegan oh okay
90 forty so it's not too bad in fact
let's find food category because we're
the most popular food categories too
okay we just do a sort so milk and
cheese they think that's the most
popular thing that's the animal product
it's milk and cheese and honestly milk
and cheese like when I'm looking at
looking at this like one weird thing is
fish one country its most in product is
fish I'm gonna guess that's an Asian
country but if you will get milk rice
and wheat products if we look at our
previous chart that we made like milk
yeah milk is a little inefficient but
milk and rice are you know pretty they
don't they don't really contribute a lot
to co2 at least and then wheat products
we products are pretty good so maybe if
I was someone who I guess was trying to
reduce co2 emissions through consuming
habits of food I would probably try to
promote just eating more wheats just
obviously more grains basically okay if
you think about like Asian food is
mostly just like rice fish I'm not
really on a milk or wheat but you know
maybe an Asian diet diet would be kind
of nice too
it's kind of interesting especially if
you think about a vegan really do have a
lot of options too because they can kind
of eat where they want for vegan or
non-vegan consumption of co2 cool okay
let's look at this again alright let's
look at do we do we look at this already
okay yeah so we did look at consumptions
for all these things but maybe she'll
get a bigger picture than just box plots
maybe we should do some density things
right might as well make it as well so
what are you nice country my category
actually you know will do will do uh
will do more vegan stuff that's kind of
cool right and then we'll do - vegan
alright so we have we have our thing and
actually we don't really need we don't
need country and yeah we just we don't
need country so let's look at ggplot a s
x equals value color will do and color
equals food category actually I'm trying
to think of how I would do this so well
I'm thinking about doing is maybe doing
like
let's go back here maybe it just like
have a kind of distribution chart of
each food category on the I guess the
y-axis and its distribution and then
also show its kind of side distributions
I'm like okay here's pork oh I guess
that doesn't make any sense
no which is do vegan distributions yeah
we'll do that so Gigi Pont is X equal
value we'll do you color it goes vegan
density okay maybe we'll help you fill
to fill oh that's why scale log 10 so
that's pretty in string actually 0.3
right in fact let's do a facet feature
plus facet crap feature scales equals
let's let's just do that so that way we
have was it do I do in row 2 area so
there we go
we have what we see here is actually
like co2 emissions or definitely there's
their mean and or whatever is definitely
to the left of animal products animal
products definitely produce more co2 and
then just on our consumption basis we
actually do consume a decent amount
however on the majority people do
consume a lot of animal products so like
some countries will actually consume a
decent amount of non animal products
however the majority of countries do
consume still just a lot and it's
something where we would probably want
it to be inverse where we wanted to have
a lot of people eating animal products
and then just some countries where they
eat a lot of a lot of animal products
but it would be kind of minority where
majority of people or majority countries
would be eating not animal so if you
just invert that that's what we would
we'll probably want to see okay right on
um yeah I think that's kind of it for
what I want to do right now what is data
set I think this is like Jesus probably
good an hour long video like a 50 minute
video but this is basically just a a
preliminary analysis honestly this data
set just isn't that large it really
isn't that big and there's only two
numerical data variables and you know
some categorical ones so it's a pretty
simple
I data said that I think actually you
could kind of deeper toes in so I'm
gonna just save this thing I'm gonna
save this thing on where's died Tuesday
and let's do tight so I'm gonna save
this and
it's tight shoes a co2 emissions when I
save this thing I'm going to knit it to
a you know kind of a hub document to
post my roomie but yeah that's basically
it
let's here I think that's all I really
need to do so if that's your yeah let's
see so yeah if you want I'm probably
gonna post more videos I mean he's
analyzing this this is my first time
doing this so I'm definitely an at all
and I might edit it to move it out but
hopefully you learned something and I'll
probably see you next week